today for our daily cancellation we're
gonna be canceling the oscars uh the
oscars have been canceled for me on a
personal level since
well forever i don't think i've ever
watched more than five minutes of an
oscar's telecast that's because i'm not
a masochist but
today we're gonna be canceling the
oscars for everybody else too you aren't
allowed to watch it either now after
this
which i think will will be one rule that
you should have no problem following
under my theocratic
uh dictatorship reading from the
hollywood reporter the headline is
film academy sets inclusion requirements
for oscars
which will take effect in 2024
and this is good as we all know because
history proves that
quotas inclusion stringent pc standards
all of that makes for great art
for example fun bit of trivia here um
the sistine chapel was painted by a
committee of
racially diverse lgbt activists it's
true
um that's a lot of people don't know
that now let's read the article
to find out about these these
requirements it says to encourage
equitable representation on and off
screen in order to
better reflect the diversity of the
movie going audience films will have to
meet
minimum requirements pertaining to
representation and inclusion to be
eligible for the best picture oscar
beginning with the 96 uh
96th oscar race uh which will recognize
achievements from 2024 and be held in
2025.
the academy of motion picture arts and
sciences announced on tuesday saying
that
in the meantime an academy inclusion
standards form
will have to be submitted to the academy
for a film to be considered for the 94th
oscars
and 95th oscars although meeting
inclusion thresholds will not yet be a
requirement
and no action will be required for films
wishing to compete for the 93rd oscars
which are to be held on april 25th
okay now there are four standards by
which the films will be judged
before being admitted into consideration
for a best picture
and they must meet two of the four
standards so here's the first of the
four standards
this is standard a it's on-screen
representation
themes and narratives that's the
category this means that at least one of
the lead actors or significant
supporting actors
is from an underrepresented racial or
ethnic group
these groups can be asian hispanic
latinx black slash african-american
indigenous native american alaskan
native middle eastern
north african hawaiian native hawaiian
or other pacific islander
or other underrepresented race or
ethnicity they might also qualify under
standard a if at least 30 percent of all
actors and secondary and more minor
roles are from at least two of the
following underrepresented groups
women racial or ethnic group
wait women racial or ethnic group lgbtq
plus
people with cognitive or physical
disabilities or who are deaf or hard of
hearing
or then there's a3 which is another way
to qualify is if the main story lines
theme or narrative of the film is
centered on an underrepresented group
such as women racial or ethnic group
lgbtq plus people with cognitive or
physical disabilities
or who are deaf or hard of hearing then
there are other standards too
uh standards b through d but frankly i
think we all get the point now
a number of things jump out jump out at
us here first of all
how is racial or ethnic group an
underrepresented group
so racial groups in general are
underrepresented in hollywood how could
that be
who are the people who've been starring
in these movies what are they robots
space aliens
they have no race at all that would
explain a lot i guess but
it seems to me that literally every
movie that's ever been made has featured
people of racial and ethnic groups
ah but you know they're they're looking
now for certain racial and ethnic groups
and they want less of other groups they
just don't want to put
it that way because it would sound
racist as hell which of course
it is second how exactly are women
underrepresented in hollywood i feel
like i see women in movies all the time
women are in movies movies are about
women
there doesn't appear to be a problem
here in fact these days you can't even
watch an action movie without
at least one of the main characters
being a 120 pound
supermodel who can somehow beat up 300
pound men
so there are plenty of women in movies
um
and the third point of course is that
this is all completely arbitrary
you know you got 30 percent of the
people in the supporting cast have to
belong to
two or more of this in that group uh
it's it's all entirely arbitrary
and the fourth point is and this is this
is the main thing i think i want us to
take away from this
this is all good this is all very good
we should be happy about this yes i am
i am canceling the oscars because of it
but it's a joyous cancellation it's uh
there should be confetti raining down
from the ceiling right now this is a
happy i am happy to do it we should be
happy about it
because there are two consequences from
this both of them very good
one is that and i think this is the less
likely consequence
that movie studios decide that it they
don't care about winning oscars anymore
uh because the oscars are such a joke uh
because it's been turned into
you know like an hr seminar now you have
to have to follow all these different
rules
uh and meet all these quotas and so
maybe movie studios will say
we don't care anymore we're just gonna
make we're going to make good movies and
uh
and as long as people watch them then it
doesn't matter to us
and if that happens then the the oscars
become entirely irrelevant
which i would say they already are but
they they are pushed even further into
irrelevance
which i would say is a positive thing
second consequence potentially is that
movie studios decide no they they want
to win the oscars
maybe they want to win even more now
because they get woke points for doing
it uh
because then it will show that not only
is it a good movie but it's a it's a
progressive movie and so they'll win a
lot of credit that way
um and so they'll they'll they'll start
making their movies
in accordance with all these ridiculous
rules so that they can win the oscars
and that will just be the end of
hollywood that will be the end of
hollywood
hollywood will officially be getting out
of the business of making art
and uh it will be fully and totally and
nothing but
in the business of progressive politics
i know you could say that that's already
happened and it has
largely but i still think that there are
you know you do
find real art sometimes coming out of
hollywood there are they they do
sometimes produce
a movie a tv show
that seems to have been made because
simply for the quality of it
for the art itself i think this could
represent
the end of that and now it's just
totally about the progressive politics
and nothing more and if that happens
then it's the end of hollywood
and it leaves a giant opening
a giant gap for somebody to come in and
fill
and make real art um because
they're still going we're we are human
beings
and we still have an appetite for art
that's not going anywhere and if
hollywood's not gonna fulfill that
appetite
um if they're not gonna satiate that
human need people have for art
then uh then somebody else will will
come in and take hollywood's place and
and i say that's good that's a positive
thing
so this is all good we should celebrate
this there's nothing there's there's no
reason to be uh
to be annoyed by it we should laugh and
be and be happy as hollywood continues
to self-destruct and commit
uh collective you know uh artistic
suicide right in front of our eyes
it's all a very good thing and though
they are canceled again it is something
that we
we do so uh joyfully
not a lot of joyful moments
unfortunately on this show but that's
that's one of them right there that we
can all take
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the entire
country if you enjoyed this video
be sure to give it a like and a
subscribe to our youtube channel so you
don't miss out on any of our content